[Musica]
quanta economia in tutti i discorsi che
abbiamo sentito finora nel design nel
food nella pharma nella medicina nella
ricerca nella plastica sociale di cui
abbiamo sentito parlare poco fa nel nel
video tantissime economia perché
l'economia è qualcosa che pervade cia
contaminati tutti l'economia è una
scienza sociale non è una scienza
deterministica che dice se fai questo
allora sicuramente avrà è quello ma è un
ascensore sociale quindi può fare errori
può essere imprecisa ma cerca di
interpretare gli eventi i fatti cerca di
prevedere quello che potrà succedere
il tema che ho voluto toccare che voglio
toccare questa sera e l'italia e
l'europa
spesso abbiamo un atteggiamento negativo
nei confronti dell'europa e spesso
l'europa ha un atteggiamento critico nei
confronti dell'italia
molto spesso qualche volta abbiamo
ragione noi qualche volta loro per
esempio io quando ho scelto questo tema
con gli organizzatori di questo
bellissimo ted per ortigia a non
immaginavo che a 60 giorni dalle
elezioni noi in italia non avessimo
ancora un governo e invece è importante
che noi abbiamo un governo nonostante
quella che oggi è una apparente
tranquillità sui mercati finanziari
lo spread è basso nessuno degli
investitori si sta preoccupando del
fatto che l'italia non ha un governo ma
attenzione perché l'anno prossimo e un
anno con una grandissima concentrazione
di scadenze è un anno chiave per
l'europa e quindi anche per l'italia
guardate quante ce ne sono nel maggio
del 2019 si vota per il rinnovo del
parlamento europeo
chi sarà il gruppo parlamentare vincente
dove riusciranno ad arrivare i movimenti
anti establishment se non cambia niente
se continua la protesta e sono proteste
di natura diverse proteste di destra
proteste di sinistra proteste contro la
mancata convergenza economica e sociale
in europa proteste contro la migrazione
contro la mancanza di sicurezza qui
proteste molto diverse altra scadenza
la commissione junker di un corpo aver
avuto tanti difetti però introdotto in
europa maggiore flessibilità rispetto a
regole molto strette molto severe e
anche lanciato un piano di investimenti
che non sarà il massimo ma che comunque
è stato importante anche per paesi come
l'italia e poi scade il mandato
dell'uomo che ha salvato l'euro in
questi anni il mandato di mario draghi a
novembre dell'anno prossimo c'è il
rinnovo e lui non può essere rieletto
un cambio di approccio di politica
monetaria può significare molto per
l'europa e infine un nuovo quadro
finanziario il nuovo bilancio europeo
2021 2027 quante risorse gli stati
membri i 27 paesi decideranno di voler
dare a progetti comuni di voler
assegnare a questa europa e come si
presenta di fronte a questi grandi
problemi
oggi l'europa l'europa è disunita non
dovremmo parlare di unione europea
dovremmo paradossalmente parlare di
disunione europea perché è disunita
perché si volendo semplificare sono
insieme due visioni completamente
diverse questa la visione solidaristica
che vede dei concetti chiave come la
condivisione dei rischi risk sharing
oppure
bene l'idea dei beni comuni cosa sono
progetti comuni finanziare l'innovazione
finanziare la sicurezza avere un
esercito comune in europa avere una
politica unica della difesa una politica
unica sull'immigrazione perché questa
visione fa fatica non riesce ad
affermarsi perché guardate se voi volete
essere solidali e relazionarvi con gli
altri il concetto chiave su cui ci si
basa e la fiducia oggi in europa manca
la fiducia tra gli stati
e quindi l'altra visione sull'europa che
è questa e potete immaginare dalla
bandiera dal palazzo del parlamento
tedesco
chi è portavoce di questa di questa
visione e una visione chiamiamola
calvinista ortodossa in cui si dice
regole ancora più strette le banche
devono ridurre i rischi nei loro
portafogli
ad esempio non devono avere tanti titoli
di stato del paese di origine
devono ridurre i crediti deteriorati e
si arriva a dire in caso di difficoltà
di uno stato membro si può procedere ad
una ristrutturazione automatica del
debito pubblico
capite che un salto ideologico molto
importante che rischia di essere
prevalente è possibile una terza via tra
queste due posizioni così differenziate
ma io credo di sì
io penso che ci voglia un europa che
rilanci gli investimenti in
infrastrutture ma non soltanto i ponti
le autostrade i porti eccetera
anche le infrastrutture non
fisiche quelle immateriali cioè la
conoscenza l'innovazione il sapere la
possibilità di andare avanti come con un
bilancio comune più forte di quello
attuale oggi il bilancio europeo è pari
ad appena l'uno per cento del pil
dell'eurozona pochissimo che cosa
bisognerebbe fare ogni stato membro
dovrebbe rinunciare a un pezzetto di
sovranità nazionale a favore di progetti
comuni
ma perché questo avvenga bisogna
ristabilire condizioni di fiducia
condizioni di reciproca stima e di
grande condivisione
abbiamo tutti bisogno di un'europa che
scaldi di più i cuori di un'europa che
crei entusiasmo
in particolare nei giovani e questo per
varie ragioni
oggi non c'è ma ci si può arrivare
l'italia l'italia è viva è tornata a
crescere
quanto a un tasso dell 1 e mezzo per
cento e poco e tanto beh è ancora
inferiore a quello che è la della media
dell'eurozona
noi 15 l'eurozona l'anno scorso 2,3
direte ma pochi decimi di punto cosa
cambiano e guardate il profilo nel corso
del tempo
l'italia è la linea blu l'eurozona e
quella rossa la differenza accumulata
nel tempo cioè se noi in tutti questi
anni
fossimo cresciuti tanto quanto
l'eurozona non tanto quanto la cina
tanto quanto l'eurozona ci ritroveremmo
oggi con un prodotto interno lordo più
alto di 313 miliardi che è diviso il
numero degli abitanti fa 5.200 euro in
più
a persona neonati compresi e con quei
soldi in più avremmo meno disoccupazione
meno debito pubblico avremmo fatto più
investimenti
staremo tutti un pochino meglio non ci
voleva molto bastava a crescere tanto
quanto l'eurozona perché non siamo
riusciti a farlo potremo dedicarci
tantissimo tempo ma forse la sintesi di
tutto e in questo in questo grafico nel
diverso andamento della produttività
cos'è la produttività e quanto si riesce
a produrre per ogni ora lavorata il
fatto di avere una produttività bassa
l'italia è quella la linea arancione ha
cresciuta solo del 5 per cento
dall'inizio del dell'unione monetaria
dal 2000 in poi la francia la spagna a
16 per cento la francia più 20 la
germania più 25 perché una produttività
bassa non vuol dire che noi lavoriamo
male vuol dire che le condizioni di
contorno in cui lavoriamo creano
problemi
se trovo molto traffico per i trasporti
mi abbassa la produttività
se devo avere molte file per fare un
certificato o se le procedure
amministrative la giustizia è lenta nel
complesso mi abbassa la produttività
ecco allora che un economista carlo
cottarelli ha scritto un libro e parla
dei sette peccati capitali dell'economia
italiana l'elenco l'evasione fiscale la
corruzione
la pubblica amministrazione poco
efficiente la giustizia lenta
il crollo demografico il divario nord
sud la difficoltà di convivere con
l'euro si chiede dice ma con questi
sette peccati capitali o vizi capitali
mi ha esteso mia i miei distrutto mi
meraviglio quasi di come mai l'economia
italiana non sia al collasso che cosa
c'è che nonostante tutto la tiene
insieme allora lui parla di peccati
capitali o di vizi capitali insomma è un
po recuperando dei ricordi del del
catechismo io sono tornato in mente le
virtù le virtù cardinali le virtù
teologali e in particolare le virtù
teologali fede speranza carità nella
religione cattolica sono qualcosa che ha
che fare con i nostri comportamenti con
i comportamenti di noi italiani
ecco qui tre virtù teologali ma ne
abbiamo anche altre sono importanti o no
guardiamo un attimo
la prima è una forte coesione familiare
in italia
se mia sorella mio fratello ha dei
problemi non chiudo la porta
se i miei figli hanno problemi anche
quando hanno più di 18 anni non li mando
fuori di casa
cerchiamo di accomodare cerchiamo di
essere familiar mente coesi e questo è
un bene per certi versi anche un male
per altri è un bene perché è un grande
ammortizzatore sociale ci si aiuta gli
uni con gli altri
forse un male paradossalmente quando il
fatto di essere a condiscendenti di
continuare a tenere tutto insieme
non si dà
la spinta nei confronti dei giovani o
degli altri per dire te la devi vedere
da solo te la devi cavare da solo però è
qualche cosa che comunque ammortizza il
disagio sociale è un elemento di
coesione
un secondo aspetto è il terzo settore il
no profit
siamo il paese con la più alta
percentuale di persone che fanno
volontariato più di 5 milioni e 200 mila
persone in italia fanno volontariato e
questo non è che vada nel calcolo del
prodotto interno lordo però è un valore
perché il terzo settore è importante per
l'economia
terzo aspetto terza virtù una
straordinaria capacità di adattamento
io credo nessuno come gli italiani è
riuscito in questi ultimi anni di crisi
profondissima in cui abbiamo visto
crollare la produzione industriale del
25 per cento
il reddito delle famiglie del 12 per
cento ma nonostante tutto abbiamo un
sistema industriale che ancora vitale
che ha reagito che non è rimasto fermo
inchiodato su vecchie convinzioni ha
reagito la popolazione soltanto alle
ultime elezioni ha votato con forza
contro l'establishment la somma di
partiti anche stabilimento ha superato
il 50 per cento ma tutto sommato non
sono neanche posizioni anti
establishment così estreme come in altri
paesi europei come in francia come in
germania allora tutto questo io penso
che abbia un valore
attenzione non deve essere un alibi per
non affrontare i problemi di prima però
è qualcosa che ci permette di guadagnare
tempo e rappresenta delle una leva
strategica su cui appoggiarci virtù
teologali ma abbiamo anche delle altre
virtù
restiamo nel gioco del catechismo
chiamiamo le virtù cardinali perché sono
dei cardini dell'economia italiana primo
il debito privato da noi è più basso che
in altri paesi del g7 in italia il
debito privato cioè delle famiglie delle
imprese arriva al 120 per cento del pil
nel regno unito
157 negli stati uniti 150 in francia 182
in giappone 163
che cosa vuol dire beh questo certamente
non vuol dire che possiamo fare più
debito pubblico perché abbiamo poco
debito privato però è un elemento
comunque di solidità finanziaria
pensate se oltre ad avere tanto debito
pubblico avessimo anche tanto debito
privato saremmo davvero nei guai
altro aspetto la ricchezza finanziaria e
immobiliare delle famiglie italiane
guardate che è pari a 9 volte il reddito
delle famiglie
l'italia rappresenta nel mondo meno
dell'uno per cento della popolazione gli
in termini di pil meno del 3 per cento
in termini di ricchezza quasi il 6 per
cento della ricchezza complessiva del
pianeta
quindi siamo un paese in media ci sono
poi le differenze naturalmente tra gli
uni e gli altri in media un paese ricco
che quindi ha un potenziale non è un
paese indebitato molto con l'estero e
dal punto di vista industriale
mi ero sentito il primo intervento sul
food sul design come quanto sia
importante allora se noi pensiamo
quali sono i settori che hanno
certamente una mega tendenza un mega
trend positivo nei prossimi dieci venti
trent'anni
uno è il biologico c'è una tendenza
sempre più forte ad andare verso il bio
e l'agroalimentare invecchiamento della
popolazione
l'altro intervento farmaceutico cura
della persona
terzo aspetto la digitalizzazione noi
abbiamo un sacco di imprese che
producono macchinari incentivati
dall'industria 4.0 e poi impianti per la
tutela ambientale la lotta
all'inquinamento anche la cina sta
investendo su quello
noi abbiamo impianti che possono aiutare
i paesi che vogliono lottare contro
l'inquinamento
ultimo aspetto è quello della
competitività delle nostre imprese per
una ragione o per l'altra noi riusciamo
a esportare ogni anno quasi 100 miliardi
ad avere scusate un saldo netto positivo
nei conti con l'estero pari a quasi 100
miliardi di dollari
siamo il quinto paese col maggiore
avanzo commerciale al mondo dopo cina
germania corea del sud e giappone
non è poco e un segno di vitalità forte
della nostra industria
allora concludendo qual è il tema io
credo che ripeto queste virtù non devono
diventare alibi per non affrontare i
problemi che abbiamo
sono però dei punti di forza delle leve
su cui possiamo appoggiarci per un
riscatto per raffrontare veramente quei
problemi e l'europa per noi è centrale
perché noi senza l'europa non avremmo
inflazione e tassi di interesse così
bassi e l'europa non può fare a meno
dell'italia però per giocare un ruolo
attivo vero in europa dobbiamo essere
credibili rispettare gli impegni che ci
pigliamo e in questo modo possiamo
davvero essere propositivi
avere una giusta iniziativa per
un'europa un po più attenta alla
crescita e non soltanto legata ai temi
delle banche del dei conti fiscali e
così via
come ho detto prima un'europa che si
scaldi di più i cuori e che ci faccia
guardare con gioia entusiasmo a quello
che può essere il futuro di più di 300
milioni di persone grazie a tutti
[Applauso]